who merci beaucoup san michele
they determine online thank you very much
fresh that my comrade relations for
your first
pulpit and the sessions offer access and their
first half of the opportunities who have
thought about second day to go
but this was an intense find that
builds and  builds
bio green deal and the arco to offer fresh
climate news show comes in the en 2015
end you were successful
it was very interesting to see the
loves and door thing and supporting to
the complex european green
deal in that bathing all the opportunity
brings alarm  corse pino
let reason for the effort of the
european green deal is destructive
climate change wiessee outside
wie auditor mijn to tackle this and
climate change and turn it into an
opportunity for the european union
knowing let right now the european
union is front runner
in there trap  me and the who want to stay
that offer of tears because there did
to offer role model here who jewelry it
is for assen potentially
new growth  strategy who god is combine
second live investment' in research and
innovation and science to fight climate
change and it was a very you can find at the
bad and possibilities we doen
scoope at developing a common red map
pair of course mother how you do that'
not every  region ss so a starting
point how to deal with how often patiently
long ago that for together regions and
sectors and ruby modifica to adapt en toe have
he turning point and therefore we have
n die bathing how to support peopl
companies and regions better  but
have to get up to stronger
i'm very keen to work very closely with
the member states on the agenda of the
european green deal
to
help in this cause i also the
international die menschen of the
one of the driving factors to day was
also  the rhino limeen convince others
like india light shine a to join
we have to be your role model and who
has bma
united en after the bold and step
forward a trial water change as
possible and became  en ze vol
of benefit for the people and for the
economy
zo thank you very much form this kind
of the part of the council
ik will be no up to the commission to
present in generally a proposal for a
sustainable job investment plan
combined met de just  when this mechanism
and then in margin reboot a pro positive
rest climate lo soldier we die on
slowly but surely the roadmap
cake we have laid out in the
communication
how you did this yesterday in the cottage
and
mff in die and bms looking for to  work
with you
president michel en out taking on this
work on mff guys think it is very
important that the budget has to reflect a
political priorities
s wel als de strategic gendo af de
council and still quite some work to do
to reach their goal becomes bed  who does
n't agree a quick agreement between the
member states pico's time is pressing
deaf and very grateful for de rijn mx
aan d'initiative youtube all right now
en wermers looking forward to work with
a en daa  r will be in close cooperation own
in time more for have very soon and
good result briefly and though you are in the
it was very cold from wie o wie can
having no no conference
especially are you in tirana
at the beginning of generally to my
channel approximately  and this was very
en coaching to see immediately de
support of all members
time to be on the side of the people in
al you ben my lee also to prepare de
reconstruction
in the region that will be necessary as
long bread and steady investment for
reconstruction de  i cute help
chariot is to us about but there will be
a long period of how the construction
that is necessary finally has me and
my reflect on the topic of afrika
everything is focused on the summit we
can let him fall in this
before deed the lot the brake
we live formulas in to the end of fabory
google hp color to colledge meeting with
the african union in her is abeba off
to which there will be an ministerial
soldier we have clio's political heat
becomes  the chance of the commission itself
how wanted to finish the first one 100
days it strategy
strategy with afrika die for dhatri
gonna give the color to call it a
meeting with the african young soldier
were able to involved in the following
our common strategy and  your image